foreign
I come from a culture of storytellers
our oldest Legends stretch back to a
time of the supernatural they're so
ancient they begin long ago before time
began when the world was both light and
dark
so I thought we could discuss the story
of story itself of legacy
in a western sense Legacy is the mark a
person leaves on history statues are
raised for the heroes for those that are
revered
in my culture we see it a bit
differently
I am title it's closest direct
translation is coming in big
I come from haidugai and archipelago off
the northwest coast of British Columbia
where on a clear day you could paint the
shores of the Alaskan panhandle from our
Northern beaches
our Legacy or the stories told about us
at least internationally is of our
Monumental Haida art our intricate
40-foot story polls our long houses and
canoes and our dance mats which are all
internationally renowned and collected
it is however our weaving that in my
opinion is the unsung hero I dare say
our entire culture and Society was
supported by our weaving be it the
clothing we wore or the Rope for our
fishermen or the baskets we wove to
collect and store our food for winter
when you weave a cedar basket you have
your warps which Cascade down your form
and you have your weft which spirals
continuously around it incorporating
itself over and under your warps to
create your basket we are I think the
weft trying to find our way around the
form being careful not to miss a step or
make a mistake or for some of us try not
to unravel all together
that's how I think of Legacy as the
weaving together of our stories passed
on as a whole and it may seem a little
esoteric but I'd love to give you an
example
250 years ago approximately 20 000
haidas thrived on the shores of
heidegway
less than 600 remained at the end of the
19th century
it was 250 years ago that an Explorer
arrived sailing on the ship Santiago
the first European to do so so what was
his legacy was it the inlet that's named
after him on heidegwai
or would I assume were the unintended
consequences of smallpox and
tuberculosis are Potlatch bands
residential schools the burning of our
masks and poles as firewood or the
collectors
who came and ransacked The Villages that
we were forced to abandon
that is the colonial Legacy
our Legacy is of those 600 haidas who
stood against the well-oiled Machinery
of an Empire that sought to destroy them
and though they have no inlets that bear
their names
their legacy can be seen every time we
stand up and say we are the Haida Nation
their legacy was on display last fall
when my clan the caiaphanus the sea lion
Town people descended from those born at
Kaio magai which
held a potlatch a potlatch is when Clans
and Nations come together for the
purposes of feasting and conducting
business like a chief being inaugurated
or a person receiving a name or a death
or a marriage we witness these business
transactions to support or even to
defend them if necessary
our Potlatch was Memorial Pool raising
honoring our late chief goth Lai
a memorial poll is in and of itself a
symbol of wealth and Status much like a
statue
where they differ is in the rings that
are carved up the pole each one
representing a pot latch the real
measure of wealth for a chief marking
each occasion that a chief and his clan
came together
and they redistributed their wealth
beyond their needs to ensure that other
clans and Nations could survive the
winter as well
my piece of the story began on a
beautiful fall afternoon the type of day
you would take a jacket with you and
only ever end up carrying it around
everywhere you go
I had no sooner landed in haidugai than
I was in a speed boat skimming across
the inlet to our traditional Village
site
or Sunshine town
and as I leapt off the bow onto the
shore I was told that we would just miss
the Royal Canadian Mounted Police or
mounties who would come over on their
speed boat to sleuth out the cause of
the smoke that was billowing into the
sky they wanted to make sure that Mod
island wasn't on fire you see there was
a bonfire going on the beach and we were
burning the branches from trees that we
had been removing to unveil big
rectangles of sunken Earth where our
long houses once stood and for me the
smoke was a bat signal in the sky the
kayathlonis have returned home
shortly after arriving I was six feet
deep in the earth and working to reach
seven
I had arrived late to the digging party
but it was my honor to complete the
final foot necessary so that the poll we
would be raising in a few days time was
seated deep enough in the Earth at the
greatest Winds of haidaguay wouldn't
topple it
what made the moment even more powerful
were the treasures we found during the
initial digging a portion of a carved
Stone Bowl blue and red glass trade
beads that came by way of Russian
Traders all the way from Bohemia
in a way we were re-awakening the
spirits that were held in the land where
external forces once drove us to abandon
those Shores now we were coming home and
they were there waiting for us
hundreds of fellow community members
plans and and relatives from our other
nations came together to help us raise
the pole
it began with an offering of food burned
in the fire a gift to our ancestors
the canoe the drums sounded announcing a
canoe coming ashore carrying the Carvers
of the pole the current chief goth lie
and the daughter of our late chief
wagona the wild man of the woods was
drummed through the village to clear out
any unwelcome spirits
and the poll which at the time lay on
the forest floor was cleansed with cedar
bows dipped in ocean water and brushed
along its length
and new offerings of glass beads were
placed into the hole so that centuries
from now long after this pole has
decayed and and returned to the Earth
they would find those Treasures from us
when the next pole was raised in its
place
thick ropes that were tied around the
midsection of the pole were stretched
down the beach to the water's edge and
all those who were able found a place
along it and from that first instruction
to pull it took only moments for the
pole to rise up and become a permanent
Beacon for the next 200 years that this
place is
and it Remains The Village of the
kayaklanas khairagai
over this two-day event of feasting and
raising the pole I stood in the role of
Master of ceremony alongside my clan
brother gaguis it's a role I inherited
from and share with my maternal Uncle
kills like sting
and during our pod latch we shared in
our songs and our stories in our
language and in our art in our
traditions and in our deep relationship
with our lands and Waters that is true
Legacy
that is the warps that make up my basket
and I am the weft that weaves myself
through them to become a basket that
everything else I learn and do in my
life can be collected in to pass on
that day I received this copper Shield
alongside of the name title
perhaps you've had the same name since
birth and will continue to have the same
name until you die well in my culture we
are often the caretakers of multiple
names over our lifetime
last year I would have first introduced
myself as get enclunts now I am title
but I do continue to hold the name good
inquis until such a time as my sister
has a child and I can pass the name on
to them it is our duty to build on the
wealth and status of our names not just
ourselves
this Shield is a witness to the creation
of that wealth and Status it is present
at significant occasions
as I received my name it was there at my
wedding and tonight it is here
witnessing me speaking to all of you
each of these occasions becomes tied to
it and one day when I pass on the name
of title I will recount all that this
Shield has witnessed and ensure that
those stories are carried on with it
it's a concept I encourage each of you
to borrow in your own unique way
the decisions we make today will make
the difference on whether or not our
descendants will have all the warps in
place to weave their own basket to
collect new knowledge and stories in we
must not allow our environment to
continue to worsen to a point where none
of us can carry on our cultures we must
be willing to do our business in the
light
make decisions in which we can proudly
celebrate with our families and our
communities or even our constituents
Mark individual achievement but
celebrate our Collective well-being
and build up our name so we are proud to
pass them on
personal Legacy is inevitable as
unavoidable as the passage of time and
while you may want to prioritize your
personal Legacy to be the one with
statues erected in your honor or Inlet
that bears your name I ask you to
consider
the collective Legacy of those unnamed
600.
they're the only reason that I'm
standing here today
will future Generations look back at us
in gratitude for all of the gifts we
have left them
I would hate for them to look back at me
and all they could say is wow he must
have been pretty impressive he even got
a statue
Hawa Mesi thank you
foreign